mais là messieurs bonsoir lendemains de
fête pour la gauche réveille un peu amer
pour la majorité le premier jour du
printemps aura souri hier à l'opposition
personne ne le conteste pas même dans
les commentaires habituellement plus
optimistes débattue la majorité a subi
un revers aux municipales les chiffres
sont là dans leur rigueur telle que
vient de les faire connaître le
ministère de l'intérieur
l'opposition prend à la majorité sur
l'ensemble des deux tours cent soixante
neuf villes de plus de 9000 habitants
rares sujets de satisfaction pour la
majorité quelques villes enlevé à
l'opposition ou deuxième tours saint
raphaël chine ont fait qu'en villeneuve
sur lot saint dié et puis paris paris où
l'addition des sièges de jacques chirac
et de michel d'ornano donnera vendredi
matin une confortable majorité aux
futures mères dont tout le monde pense
qu'il s'appellera jacques chirac mais
cela fait peu de résultats positifs et
c'est donc un bilan assez sévère
conduite évoqué tout à l'heure en tête à
tête valéry giscard d'estaing et raymond
barre à montbard qui vient de sortir
à l'instant de l'elysée mais les
journalistes vous allez le voir sont un
petit peu restés sur leur faim
la roma niveau matériel est envisagée
pourquoi voulez vous des choses
pareilles c'est la question monsieur les
dernières vous ce soir de mauvaises
pensées se prémunit sa semaine dernière
vous nous parliez ce premier tour alors
le deuxième est arrivé après votre
commentaire d'hier soir matignon
quels enseignements tirez-vous de ce
deuxième single renseignements que je
tire sont aussi lieu dans le commentaire
je publie il était bref monsieur le
premier ministre
mais contre l'inter écrit nous sommes
des gens nouveaux visuels et complets
entrer dans l'armée car non d'accueillir
une conférence ce soir c'est un petit
peu brouillon et le premier ministre
n'est guère loquace alors reprenons
maintenant détail carte à l'appui ce
bilan des municipales avec tout d'abord
se rappelle des membres du gouvernement
battu michel durafour pierre brou rené
haby michel d'ornano norbert se garer
puis au 1er tour vous le saviez antoine
ruffenach et françois girault en vrai
aussi que l'on disait en situation
difficile à château thierry est en
revanche réélu en améliorant ses
positions et christian poncelet
contrairement à ce qui a été dit pardon
pour lui a bien été réélu à remiremont
dans les vosges donc maintenant un bilan
précis pour paris et pour la province
pour une participation globale noël
copains très très légèrement inférieure
à celle du premier tour oui cette
première carte et la carte des progrès
de la de l'opposition il s'agit des
villes de plus de 30 mille habitants sur
221 une ville de plus de 30000 habitants
l'opposition si l'on fait le total des
deux tours en a pris
soixante-et-une à la majorité 40 vont au
ps et 21h au pc parmi les principales
villes qui ont été gagnés au deuxième
tour
rennes angers nantes poitiers
villeurbanne chambéry et puis
saint-etienne montpellier et béziers
le parti socialiste gagne plus de mairie
que le parti communiste mais celui ci
par contre grâce à l'accord d'unité de
la gauche gagne davantage de sièges
ils doublent presse que le nombre de ses
sièges ainsi on voit que la carte
géographique la carte politique de la
france est en train peu à peu de se
transformer la progression de la gauche
est répartie un peu sur l'ensemble du
territoire mais particulièrement sur
plusieurs régions
un ensemble rhône alpes un autre
ensemble région parisienne et champagne
et également quelques grandes villes de
l'ouest
pourquoi ces transformations il faudra
sans doute affiner les analyses que l'on
a pu faire jusqu'à maintenant il y a
sans doute une raison conjoncturelle une
raison sociale quel problème de l'emploi
et peut-être aussi en particulier dans
l'ouest une raison plus profonde c'est
l'évolution d'un certain électorat
centriste d'inspiration chrétienne
maintenant la carte de la majorité de la
moins garni oui alors il ne s'agit même
pas là de progrès mais tout simplement
des villes de plus de 30 mille habitants
qui sont restés à la majorité on voit
que la majorité résiste assez bien dans
le nord est également dans le sud ouest
qui est pourtant habituellement réputé
comme étant de gauche ce que l'on peut
remarquer aussi c'est qu'il ya quand
même une ville qu est une ville conquise
quimper dès le premier tour et trois
villes qui ont changé de camp cambrai
maubeuge et perpignan mais il s'agit en
fait de mer qui eux avaient changé
d'étiquette paris maintenant est là
c'est assez nette
apparemment laisse de l'opposition
l'ouest à la majorité oui nous avons
donc en couleur orange les secteurs les
arrondissements qui sont maintenant
détenus par l'opposition en bleu foncé
les couleurs les secteurs qui
appartiennent à la majorité deux points
importants pour le deuxième tour l'échec
de monsieur d'ornano dans le 18e
arrondissement qu'il n'a pas pu
reprendre à la gauche comme il
l'espérait et puis et la défaite de
monsieur dominati qui a perdu le
deuxième et troisième arrondissement au
bénéfice de la gauche il y à un total
109 conseillers municipaux de paris la
majorité en détient 69 et la gauche 40
monsieur chirac a dès aujourd'hui
constitué son groupe et il peut espérer
avec quelques ralliements en venant des
listes de monsieur d'ornano avoir même
sans doute la majorité absolue mais je
vous le répète donc élection du maire
vendredi matin à la loupe des résultats
beaucoup plus marquée qu'à l'habitude
dans ce type d'élection qui en général
se traduit toujours par une certaine
stabilité
inutile de vous dire que la presse en
fait ses choux gras la france est rose
dit libération
feu la majorité pour le quotidien de
paris la france à gauche titre le matin
de paris
la punition pour france soir une vague
de la gauche amplifiées mais paris a
tenu dix l'aurore poussée de la gauche
nettement accentuée pour le figaro et
figaro alors que l'humanité étrangement
discrète se contente de titrer la gauche
accentue sa poussée je ne parle pas des
quotidiens de province mais dans
certaines villes c'est avec une certaine
surprise que les habitants se sont
réveillés avec des municipalités de
gauche
l'un des exemples les plus frappants
c'est un exemple du premier tour rens
prince jusque alors tenu par le
gaulliste jean taittinger et depuis
dimanche
enlevé par l'union de la gauche dirigée
par le communiste claude lamblin prince
une ville que jean-louis le scène est
allé radioscopie avec une équipe de hand
de tout temps reims a été ce qu'on
appelle une ville bourgeoise
encore faut-il bien voir que depuis 1950
les grandes familles du textile ont
disparu pour laisser la place aux
entreprises de mécanique et de
métallurgie l'arrivée des banques
l'implantation d'une université de onze
mille étudiants ont fait le reste
le champagne ne représente plus qu'une
petite partie des ressources de la ville
une ville qui a grandi rapidement trop
rapidement peut-être en dix années
cinquante quatre mille personnes sont
venues s'installer arras
la bourgeoisie rémoise rester ce qu'elle
était mais la population ayant grandi de
façon importante il y à de nouvelles
couches de population de nouveaux cadres
qui sont venus à reims qu'il n'était pas
d'origine rémoise
ce qui a changé certainement la
structure sociologique de la bourgeoisie
rémoise il n'empêche que la victoire de
la gauche à reims qui plus est d'une
liste menée par un communiste de 39 ans
cette victoire peut surprendre
les rémois encore aujourd'hui ont du mal
à expliquer aux personnes finalement
vous avez un large dos lorsqu'elle est
rémois essayer que ça change je ne sais
pas mais moi je passais parce que les
gens ne sont pas satisfaits la politique
actuelle donc ils ont l'espoir du
changement quand on est en place pendant
de nombreuses années
fini par s'endormir aussi quand même
dans une affaire commerciale
donc il faut se réveiller un peu de
temps en temps
pourrait évoluer les choses la campagne
électorale à reims a été
particulièrement calme
il faut dire que dès le premier tour la
situation était claire deux listes en
présence
une pour toute la majorité une pour
l'ensemble de la gauche ce qui est clair
aussi c'est que la majorité était
persuadé de gagner et l'opposition de
perdre même si les deux candidats s'en
défendent aujourd'hui en 1973 les
élections cantonales sur quatre nouveaux
cantons la gauche remporte 3 en 1974 aux
élections présidentielles le candidat du
programme commun fait 52 % des voix en
1976 aux élections cantonales de nouveau
nous confortant notamment notre avance
le succès d'une liste de gauche aux
élections municipales pouvait être une
chose à mettre en oeuvre
j'ai consolider nos positions dans ma
propre circonscription les quartiers
périphériques qui ont été construits
depuis quelques années n'ont pas eu les
mêmes résultats favorables et en ville
compte tenu du travail considérable que
j'ai effectué de nombreuses années la
population pense et jean falala sera élu
il s'en est suivi une certaine
démobilisation de l'électorat d'une
partie de mon électorat et cette
confiance a fait qu' il y a eu le moins
de votes ans chez ceux qui ne soutenait
que chez ceux qui combattaient le fait
est que reims vivait jusqu'à présent
dans la quiétude les salaires étaient à
peu près équivalents à ceux de paris
mais depuis 1974 la situation de
l'emploi s'est détériorée dans une
région habituée aux sur emplois voire
6000 travailleurs au chômage inquiète
il ne fait aucun doute que cela aussi a
contribué à la victoire de la gauche
dimanche dernier
maintenant je prémonitoire ensemble
maintenant alain duhamel et s'ils ont
quelques projections sur l'avenir avec
d'abord cette évidence quoi que l'on
fasse
nous sommes depuis hier et peut-être
depuis plus longtemps entrée dans une
compétition électorale permanente alors
première question que va faire la gauche
ne peut faire la gauche maintenant on va
d'abord elle va solliciter et ensuite
comme toujours quand une tactique qui
gagne
elle a peu intérêt en changer c'est à
dire que françois mitterrand va
continuer à se montrer finalement
relativement prudents et modérés et que
georges marchais je pense jusqu'à
présent en tout cas s'est montré
relativement discret c'est souvent une
attitude quand le lancement de la gauche
est en pertes de progression oui on l'a
vu dans ce type de l'humanité cette
absence de triomphalisme alors ps pc qui
a gagné vraiment écouté les deux ont
gagné c'est la première chose à
l'oreille mais ils n'ont pas gagné pour
les mêmes raisons je dirais que le parti
socialiste a gagné d'abord parce que
maintenant il a démontré une fois de
plus au moment des municipales ce qui
avait déjà montré au moment des
cantonales et quelquefois dans une
élection législative partielle te dire
que l'électorat allemand
incontestablement il est de loin
aujourd'hui le premier parti de france
comme pouvaient l'être les gaullistes ya
dix ans bon alors c'est une première
raison c'est une raison de satisfaction
et là à travers les chiffres on le voit
très bien puisque eux seuls les
socialistes ont maintenant plus du tiers
des villes de plus de 30 mille habitants
ce qui est énorme
une première raison la seconde raison
qui est moindre méfait qui n'est pas
négligeable non plus c'est que
au premier tour au moment des primaires
avec les communistes il les avait
largement emporté 13 sur 17 qui était
très important
alors pour les communistes ya deux
raisons de satisfaction la première ce
que s'engouffrant dans le sillon
socialiste ils ont eu aussi des gains
très importants et en particulier une
diversification géographique qui
pourraient être importantes
et puis la deuxième chose qu'on a vu
hier on a beaucoup insisté là dessus
c'est que manifestement ils ne font plus
peur en tout cas à l'électorat non
communiste mais là pour remettre de
l'île soit commise ce soit la nappe à la
vente et pour eux pratiquement c'est
très importante c'est ce qui leur a
permis de gagner des villes qui n'était
pas évidente comme saint-etienne même
question à l'intérieur de la majorité
qui a gagné qui a perdu les centristes
les airs et indépendant a perdu hier et
tout le monde a perdu l'un tire la
majorité il faut faire une différence
entre paris et la province
a paris je dirais que le dynamisme
politique personnelle de jacques chirac
a sans doute permis à la majorité de
limiter les dégâts et en particulier on
a plus insisté sur le fait qu'ils
conservent sans doute la mairie avec
concerne la mairie alors qu'en réalité
la gauche a quand même progressé à paris
bon sur la province le phénomène
essentiel c'est que toutes les
formations de la majorité quelle que
soit leur style leur orientation leurs
leaders ont tout perdu dans des
proportions relativement comparable plus
particulièrement quand il s'agit du cds
de jean lecanuet ou des radicaux mais
aussi du rpr et je dirais même en
proportion pour les villes de plus de 30
mille habitants un tout petit peu plus
du rpr que des républicains indépendants
l'avenir maintenant l'avenir immédiat
d'abord ceux dont on parle
remaniement réorganisation de la
logistique ardian oui alors il ya deux
problèmes à court terme éventuel
s'agissant de la majorité le premier
c'est la constitution dont on parle
depuis longtemps il faut dire mon fils
devient urgente de leur point de vue une
sorte de grand parti libéral alors ça
vous savez que la tendance naturelle des
gaullistes et ont tendance à la cohésion
et au rassemblement et que la tendance
naturelle de tous les autres de la
majorité c'est une tendance à la
dispersion alors on parle toujours
beaucoup on en parle spécialement ces
jours ci d'autres tentatives de
constitution d'un grand parti libéral
qui regrouperait les non gaullistes de
la majorité avec une véritable
organisation avec peut-être un michel
d'ornano comme chef de file pour ben oui
on en parle en tout cas on pourrait
mobiliser beaucoup des ministres
politique quelle que soit leur étiquette
quand ils sont pas gaulliste jean
remaniement maintenant maintenant son
salarié
alors non le remaniement jurait que qui
a deux choses et la question de la date
et puis à d'autre part la question du
type de remaniement alors pour la dette
jeu direct de toute façon il faut que ce
soit avant la session donc avant le 2
avril mais que psychologiquement pour le
président de république que le plus
court sera mieux évidemment puisque
celui d'un an exactement de reprendre
les choses en main et puis alors il ya
la question du style de leurs lâches des
cas deux solutions il y en a une qui
consisterait à faire un replâtrage en
disant monsieur x ou monsieur y se sont
fait battre dans leur propre mairie faut
qu'ils s'en aillent on va reprendre
monsieur z
je dirais que j'ai l'impression que sur
les français ça ne produirait pas un
choc bouleversant aurait une seconde
solution dont on parle à tort ou à
raison qui elle donnerait probablement
un sentiment de pugnacité plus grande
qui consisterait par exemple à
constituer une sorte de gouvernement de
techniciens autour de raymond barre les
ministres politiques en revanche et en
se concentrant sur les responsabilités
politiques mais on en parle seulement de
voir à long terme maintenant les
élections anticipées apparemment c'est
repoussé l'instant les élections
anticipées franchement je vois pas du
tout les avantages de la majorité
auraient à provoquer des élections et
basculé pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'aujourd'hui elle les perdrait
alors je vois pas du tout pourquoi elle
le ferait et puis dernière question la
réorganisation du mode de scrutin le
changement excellence assez différent
normalement je veux dire que on pense
généralement que le changement de mode
de scrutin ne se fera pas avant les
prochaines élections législatives ne
serait ce que parce que si la majorité y
toucher maintenant bien que la gauche
soit favorable au scrutin proportionnel
ça donnera le sentiment au micro cherche
un peu triché avec le suffrage lors cela
étant je pense que c'est tout de même
une arme de réserve au cas où il y
aurait une crise à l'intérieur de la
majorité parce que la perspective de la
proportionnelle pourrait changer les
rapports de force dans la majorité dont
just une arme de dissuasion
voilà reste à savoir si la majorité va
se réconcilier apparemment ça sera
difficile si l'on en juge par ce que
l'on a vu hier dans notre débat commun
antenne d europe 1 ce sera également
difficile si l'on en juge par les propos
de michel debré à rtl aujourd'hui
l'absence d'autorités gouvernementales
et un certain comportement présidentiel
ne sont pas dit il
apprécié par la majorité de l'opinion un
jugement que jacques chirac semble
ratifié avec lui beaucoup plus de
souplesse la majorité dit il doit à
changer de stratégie
il vaut mieux désigner l'adversaire
sous-entendu cesson nous combattre les
uns les autres
alors les conséquences pratiques de ces
municipales d'abord indépendamment de la
simple gestion des villes
il y aura une répercussion sur l'
équilibre au sein des conseils régionaux
et sur l'élection des sénateurs puisque
les conseillers municipaux sont souvent
de grands électeurs
les conséquences économiques en revanche
semble assez minces puisque le franc n'a
pas paru affecté aujourd'hui par les
résultats du second tour il est resté
stable en revanche à la bourse de paris
les valeurs françaises ont un petit peu
fléchi à la dune
après les hommes politiques banquiers
actionnaires et épargnants ont à leur
tour fait leurs comptes
quand la gauche monte la bourse de paris
baisse on l'a vérifié une fois de plus
aujourd'hui
les valeurs françaises ont perdu un peu
plus de 4%
premier visé est évidemment les titres
menacé de nationalisation par le
programme commun
les acheteurs se sont tournés vers les
quelques valeurs refuges du marché
lingots d'or et l'emprunt 4 50% 1973
c'est à dire l'ex emprunts pinay qui se
retrouvent au plus haut des plus hauts à
629 francs pourtant sur le marché des
changes barisien le franc ne semble pas
avoir été très attaquées
seul le franc suisse gagnait quelques
fractions à 1 5096 franc sans doute les
banquiers suisses seront qui une fois
encore les vrais gagnants de ces
élections
voilà avec vous maintenant edmond maire
et si on voir s'il ya des conséquences
sociales cette poussée de la gauche
poussé à laquelle vous n'êtes pas
d'étranger puisque si je me trompe les
nouveaux maires d'angers et de braises
sont issus de vos rangs si vous voulez
ce qui nous fait encore plus plaisir
c'est que dans une région comme la
bretagne qui étaient traditionnellement
plutôt conservatrice l'action en
profondeur de la cfdt
l'action permanente de prise de
conscience du syndicalisme fait que peu
à peu des arguments électoraux le
marketing politique
l'utilisation écoles privées bien
d'autres choses nous ont n'ont pas
résisté au fait le fait c'est qu'il y à
un chômage important c'est qu'il ya des
régions entières qui n'arrive pas à
avoir de perspective qui ne s'en sortent
pas les faits ses clients un plan barre
une politique gouvernementale économique
et sociale on
refusé par la population et c'est cela
qui explique à notre sens très largement
les progrès de la gauche car elles
offrent des perspectives
alors est ce que la poussée du ps ne
veut pas vous entraîner à coller
davantage à lui a manifesté un soutien
encore plus actif au parti socialiste
lui même ya une très grande différence
entre le parti socialiste et la cfdt
c'est que c'est un parti et que nous
sommes un syndicat c'est déjà une
évidence mais il faut le dire et
d'autres chopin actions et d'autre part
nous sommes une organisation massivement
implanté dans la classe ouvrière
chacun sait que le parti socialiste a
fait de grands progrès mais dans les
entreprises dans les luttes sociales
il n'a pas encore la même présence que
dans d'autres catégories de la
population
c'est une raison de fond ajouté à
d'autres qui font que nous croyons que
les relations normales et saine entre le
mouvement syndical et les partis et
entre autres entre la cfdt et le parti
socialiste sont une c'est une attitude
de confrontation de discussion de
recherche de convergences mais dans la
liberté
voir dans la confrontation quand ce sera
nécessaire et non merci est un secret
pour personne vous souhaiter la victoire
de la gauche oblige la tire lorsque vous
n'êtes pas tenté de modérer un petit peu
pour l'instant vous troupes dans la
mesure où vous ne voulez pas inquiéter
un certain électorat
eh bien écoutez nous refusons absolument
de nous inscrire dès maintenant dans une
attitude d'attentes préélectorale nous
disons même que ce type d'attitude
serait très dangereux elle laisserait
faire la restructuration des entreprises
se dire au profit du patronat
avec le chômage avec la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat et en même temps elle ne
servira à rien à gauche
servir la gauche c'est à dire réaliser
les conditions politiques du changement
c'est mener une action syndicale qui
obtiennent des résultats par la
négociation qui donne confiance à la
population et c'est faire en sorte que
peu à peu
effectivement il n'y est pas simplement
une légère majorité de gauche mais lier
un franc succès qui permettent d'aller
nettement vers des transformations plus
profonde pourtant pour l'instant on vous
sent quand même un petit peu silencieux
est ce que sont vos trucs qui ne sont
pas très combative en ce moment mais
écoutez je crois que à vous
vous êtes assez osé quand même de nous
poser la question lui a été infligée
nous permettait justement vous êtes une
une télévision importante et pendant
toute une période toute la période que
nous voulons passer la vie sociale a été
beaucoup moins présente chez vous comme
chez vos confrères les autres hommes de
lévis comme dans les radios comme dans
les journaux la vie sociale a disparu de
ce pays apparemment
or il y avait des conflits fort
important une action qui se mène très
réel qui explique d'ailleurs les
résultats des élections et c'est un peu
dommage de passer ainsi dans les grands
moyens d'information d'une période
politique à une période plus sociale
nous disons que la vie sociale en
permanence et la vie politique doivent
être présentes y compris dans les grands
médias d'information
edmond maire imaginons la gauche au
pouvoir dans un an donc aux prochaines
législatives
est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas que la
situation risque d'être difficile pour
vous on l'a vu par exemple en
grande-bretagne où les syndicats ont été
obligés d'accepter une baisse de 5 à 6%
du pouvoir d'achat une craignez pas ce
type de situation nous ne le croyons pas
nous sommes en train à la cfdt de mettre
au point une plateforme de
revendications et d'objectifs de
transformation de notre pays à partir de
laquelle nous voulons aussi bien
négocier avec le gouvernement actuel
s'il enfin ils disent négocier que
négocier avec un gouvernement de gauche
et le type de revendication de
propositions que nous ferons sont nature
jointe au programme qu on les gouverne
les partis politiques de gauche
jointe au programme du gouvernement ou
confronter l'un avec l'autre sont de
nature à trouver des solutions réelles
mais c'est vrai qu'il faudra peut-être
aller plus loin
coût en sont encore aujourd'hui les
partis de gauche
nous pensons que les propositions des
partis de gauche par exemple en ce qui
concerne l'emploi des femmes qui est un
des problèmes cruciaux de l'heure et qui
explique que beaucoup de femmes sont
passées là aux élections municipales
d'un vote conservateur un vote
quelquefois de gauche mais le plus
souvent un vote marginal un vote
écologiste quelquefois à votre d'extrême
gauche
bon nous croyons que sur le travail des
femmes comme sur le type de
développement la qualité de la vie la
vie collective dans les quartiers dans
les régions il y a des propositions plus
précises à faire plus mobilisatrices
affaire n.mamère pour l'instant ps pc
même combat mais pas toujours
chose pour la cgt la cfdt par exemple
vous avez une conception différente de
la gestion des entreprises
comment est ce que vous allez mettre
d'accord d'ici un an là vous savez comme
nous sommes pour l'autogestion nous
sommes conséquent nous sommes pour la
propriété sociale des grands moyens de
production
nous sommes donc pour les
nationalisations mais nous ne voulons
pas de nationalisation de type 1945
celle que nous connaissons actuellement
qui sont en fait des étatisation c'est
l'état qui domine ses grandes
entreprises les travailleurs ayant très
peu d'influencé
alors nous nous disons si la gauche
nationalise et nous pensons que
nationalisera nous voulons absolument
qu'il y ait des instances locales c'est
dans d'ateliers de services de
département dans les entreprises
nationalisées ou les travailleurs aient
un réel pouvoir n'ont pas tous le
pouvoir de l'entreprise sas à partir au
plan les grands investissements mais un
pouvoir réel direct sur leurs conditions
de travail sur les rapports avec leur
chef sur les investissements concernant
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
ils font ce pouvoir de base pour qu' il
y a une vie plus démocratique plus réel
dans les entreprises les jeunes agit là
il faut épousseter le prend en main
nous croyons que la négociation entre
les partis qui se réclament du programme
commun et les syndicats et notamment la
cfdt fait une phase indispensable
nous ne sommes pas d'accord pour dire
que nous faisons confiance totalement au
parti pour réaliser l'espoir du peuple
non le mouvement syndical à sa place il
a ses propositions et il faudra que
toutes les négociations dès que ce
gouvernement ça arrive au pouvoir
ce qui n'empêche pas qu'en attendant
nous disons que dès maintenant nous
voulons négocier avec ce gouvernement
nous voulons que le premier ministre le
ministre travaille le président du cnpf
change d'attitude
dès maintenant nous sommes prêts à
réaliser des progrès c'est urgent
c'est urgent devant la montée du chômage
c'est urgent devant le blocage du
pouvoir précisément là j'apprends à
l'instant que la cgt réclament
l'ouverture immédiate comme vous de
négociation tripartite au niveau
national te dire gouvernement syndicats
et sncf vous étiez d'accord et vous êtes
courant on nous sommes d'accord nous en
sommes c'est pour faire plusieurs
lettres successives a dressé la dernière
à monsieur bart remonte au mois de
novembre dernier voyez c'est pas très
vieux c'est tous les trimestres nous
rappelons notre volonté de négociation
ce avec pour l'instant 2
s'ils refusent comme les résultats des
élections municipales sont peut-être de
nature à le faire réfléchir
peut-être nos nouvelles démarches auront
tél enfin un début de résultat il aura
très bientôt a demandé à merci beaucoup
nous changeons de sujet de continent
même nous restons quand même en pleine
élection je veux parler de l'inde l'un
d'eux qui a voté pendant trois jours et
qui est en train de changer de régime
la défaite de madame gandhi qui n'est
pas encore tout à fait définitif car le
dépouillement du scrutin est très long
là-bas pendant des allures de
catastrophe pour elle elle est elle même
battu dans sa propre circonscription
ainsi que son fils en qui certains
voyaient un successeur possible de la
fille de nero cinq de ses ministres sont
battus l'un d'entre eux a même assez mal
encaissé le choc puisqu'il a giflé le
magistrat qui lui annonçait sa défaite
il a passé la nuit en prison alors tout
de suite la correspondance de notre
envoyé spécial claude carré je vous
demanderais de prêter l'oreille car le
son vient de loin
les gens ne sont pas heureux ici ça a
été dur aura village à côté il ya des
bagarres et des morts on s'est battu
avec les policiers
ils sont venus dans le village pour
attraper les gens pour les emmener de
force sur le plateau elle est là on les
a stérilisé
maintenant on a peur nous voulons
restaurer les droits fondamentaux du
peuple indien empêcher que cette période
noire ne se répète
nous voulons que les indiens puis ce
livre comme des êtres humains nous comme
des esclaves ou des animaux il faut
aussi essayer d'atténuer la misère tenez
du travail donné le droit de s'exprimer
bref donner toute la liberté aux indiens
voilà un autre premier ministre en
situation difficile c'est l'anglais
james callaghan menacé par une motion de
censure déposée par les conservateurs
très menacé même les nationalistes
écossais et gallois votre encontre le
gouvernement mercredi tout va se jouer à
une voix est l'un des députés
travaillistes vient d'être frappé d'une
crise cardiaque
c'est vous dire yasser arafat toujours à
la tête de l'ol paie facilement réélu
par cette fraction importante de la
résistance palestinienne il entama 48
ans un nouveau mandat d'une certaine
façon c'est la continuation de la ligne
modérée du mouvement palestinien
enfin à moscou un discours dur de leonid
brejnev devant le congrès des syndicats
soviétique sévère pour les dissidents de
son propre pays et pour ce qu'il appelle
l'ingérence des pays de l'otan dans les
affaires du zaïre au kremlin au pied de
la monumentale statue de lenine devant
kuti mille personnes monsieur brejnev a
condamné en premier lieu les livraisons
d'armes de certains pays de l'otan
oseille les traits tirés
parlant parfois avec difficulté le
secrétaire général du parti communiste
soviétique à candé vient ensuite avec
force les tentatives officielle de
washington de s'ingérer dans les
affaires intérieures de l'urss à lyon
était faite l'a directement à
l'entretien accordé par le président
carter aux dissidentes bosque c'est du
reste la première fois que ce problème
est évoqué dans un discours par monsieur
préfinale toujours au sujet des
dissidents monsieur brejnev s'est montré
très ferme des mesures at il dit ont été
prises contre des activités de ces
renégats qui menace la sécurité de 260
millions de ce kit en conclusion de ce
discours parfois violents et dont la
partie centrale était un avertissement
monsieur carter le numéro un soviétique
a réaffirmé en ce qui concerne le moyen
orient
l'importance de la conférence
genève pour l'urss la fin d'un grand
après le france qui roule toujours dans
le port du havre
c'est le porte-avions arromanches qui
est en train de mourir mais sa fin est
beaucoup plus proche
après 3 sur 6 la date de sa vente est
fixé à demain et si tout se passe comme
prévu sa mort ne sera pas très glorieuse
racheté par un ferrailleur il sera tout
simplement découpé comme une simple
boîte de conserve dans la région de
toulon l'opération vous le pensez bien
très longue et qui aura au moins le
mérite de donner du travail à un certain
nombre d'ouvriers de la région le
colosse c'est le nom de baptême que lui
avait donnés les anglais à sa sortie des
chantiers de newcastle le 3 septembre
en 47 il passe sous les couleurs
françaises et prend le nom d'arromanches
afin de commémorer le débarquement du 6
juin 1944
au cours de sa longue carrière le porte
avions a parcouru près de 35 fois le
tour de la terre maintenant sa course
est terminée
il attend son dernier voyage vers les
chantiers de démolition à 34 ans même un
colosse est un vieux bateau destiné au
chalumeau des ferrailleurs toulonnais
ça me rend bien triste d'autant plus que
je les connais au début de ma marine en
1952 en indochine
je me retrouve aujourd'hui ici à bord
juste avant qu'ils s'en aillent au
cimetière disons alors évidemment ça me
rend bien triste quoi j'ai partagé des
souvenirs avec ce bateau oui bien sûr
j'en ai partagé en indochine avec les
avions à hélice tout notamment
et puis en dernier lieu juste avant son
désarmement des avions réaction c'était
2 à 2 aéronaval complètement différent
quoi on avait cité pas les mêmes joies
et les mêmes le même travail fait
pendant plusieurs années il a re manche
est le seul vrai porte avions de combat
français
il participe à quatre campagnes en
indochine lors de l'encerclement de dien
bien phu il est le seul à pouvoir
soutenir les batailles ont encerclé au
prix de lourdes pertes
il est cité trois fois à l'ordre de
l'armée et deux fois à l'ordre du corps
d'armée ses marins ont le privilège de
porter la fourragère
il passe de l'aviation à hélices au
moteur à réaction trente mille appareils
ont fait crier leurs pneus sur le pont
la romanche avec ses 211 m a rempli son
contrat
sa mission est terminée la coque à
présent mises à prix ne peut plus dire
son nom il a été effacé sauf dans la
mémoire de ceux qui ont vécu à bord et
qui se souviennent que les coursives
était désigné par des noms de rues et
que l'une d'elle s'appelait même la rue
de la paix
la du roman placé pour terminer qu'un
réseau de drogue y vient d'être
démantelé à besançon et dans l'ensemble
du département du doubs un énorme réseau
apparemment puisque cinquante et une
personnes ont été inculpées que 28
d'entre elles sont écrouées
je pense que nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler et puis deux petits flashs
sportif
encore une victoire pour le suédois
stenmark à arreux une victoire qui
compte pour la coupe du monde de ski
alpin puis encore une autre victoire en
cyclisme cette fois pour le belge freddy
maertens
premier leader aujourd'hui de la semaine
catalane il a enlevé les deux demis
tronçon de l'étape
la météo pour terminer le temps restera
dans l'ensemble frais et assez nuageux
avec des pluies des averses vous ne
voyez surtout sur le quart sud est et il
neigera au dessus de 1000 mètres environ
les éclaircies seront réservées à
l'ouest et au nord du pays merci d'être
resté en notre compagnie vous avez un
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité à
23h35 avec pierre-alain après un débat
chez philippe bouvard où l'on parlera de
l'avenir de la télévision
bonne soirée à tous à demain